everyone it's my pleasure to welcome
High Representative ice president
federica mogherini and Commissioner for
transport Violetta booths in the press
room today to present the joint
communication on connecting Europe and
Asia that was just adopted they will
both make representations and then we'll
take a couple of questions on this issue
specifically since time is limited but
the later on in the afternoon we will
have a technical briefing for further
details in case you will have more
questions and there is a very
comprehensive Peck press back also
available and following this Alexander
will address other issues from the
college agenda so we really keep this on
connectivity today with this I give the
floor to High Representative Thank You
Maya I'm very pleased to be here today
together with the Alita to present our
vision that we presented today in
college how to better connect Europe and
Asia let me say from the beginning I was
just last week in Strasbourg at the
European Parliament plenary discussing
our relations with China it immediately
came up how relevant it is and it must
be our work on connectivity from a
European perspective because we are as
Europeans very fortunate to live in a
highly connected European Union our
internal market free movement of people
mutual recognition of qualifications
energy union free roaming all these
connections have created opportunities
for European Union citizens businesses
and investors and contributed to a
better standard of living across Europe
these connections these benefits have
been achieved through the European Way
so today we have adopted our proposal on
how to bring the European way to
connectivity in our work to implement to
increase connectivity between Europe and
Asia and it is based on three main
principles three main blocks
sustainability a comprehensive approach
and rules based
approach first on sustainability we
believe that connectivity can work only
if it's sustainable from an economic
from a physical from an environmental
from a social point of view second
connectivity must be comprehensive which
means that it must focus on all
different aspects from Transport which
is obviously the key but also including
digital energy and human dimensions
third connectivity must be established
according to international rules and
regulations which are crucial for goods
services capital and people to move
efficiently and fairly and this I would
say is specifically the European way of
moving forward on these points as well
as another's today together with
Violetta as well as with other members
of the college we have set out how this
European Union approach to sustainable
connectivity can be expanded
specifically in and towards the region
with the biggest demand for
infrastructure and the region with the
highest predictor growth in the world
which is Asia and to do it in a way that
will be beneficial both for us in Europe
in Asia and also for the entire planet
we will do this in three ways first we
will build new connections and networks
between Europe and Asia
we will do this through transport
networks and I will leave this to you
later in a moment we will also build
digital and energy networks and we will
continue to promote human exchanges and
mobility as a way to build connections
to facilitate mutual understanding and
to share ideas this is at the end of the
day the basis of connections between
Europe and Asia since thousands of years
secondly we need to build and strengthen
partnerships for a common approach to
connectivity many of these partnerships
already exists with China for example we
have a bilateral connectivity platform
where we meet to discuss synergies but
also to discuss the different points of
view might have on the regional level we
work together with ASEAN and this shows
for example that this cooperative
approach also on connectivity works and
brings
results that are good for us and I go
for them and for the rest of the region
and at the international level you know
well that the European Union is at the
heart of global cooperation and the
strongest supporter of multilateralism
and of the international rules-based
global architecture and once again in a
few days from now in New York at the
General Assembly will have the
opportunity to do so on different
aspects for beyond connectivity
connectivity cannot be confined to
regional pockets cannot exclude
legitimate actors and put environmental
considerations last we need common
standards we need common rules and for
this reason European Union is working
with international and European
standardization organisations the
International Energy Agency the World
Trade Organization and other key
organizations with a global mandate
finally we have looked at how to
leverage sustainable investments for
connectivity projects Asia is estimated
to need around 1.3 trillion euros per
year for infrastructure investments
that's a huge amount of money if we can
support them the opportunities for the
European companies are clearly there the
European Union as all the recent years
developed innovative and sustainable
ways of leveraging finance for
investment just think of the Yoker plan
but also through regional investment
facilities and in the next multi-annual
financial framework you know that the
Commission has proposed to increase the
European Union External action budget to
123 billion euros for the period 21:27
which is an increase of 30% compared to
this current period and included in this
proposal there is an investment
framework for external action with 60
billion euros in guarantees for external
investment so connectivity in and with
Asia would stand to benefit enormously
from these proposals that are now going
to be discussed by the council and
Parliament and I'm sure that if the
decision will be confirmed in that
direction we will have three or four
times more of the European here
investments compared to today as a
result of this increase so I finish here
it is something big it is something
consistent with our overall global
approach it is something that could be
good not only for our people but also
for our businesses and I know that our
friends not only in Europe but also in
Asia are very much looking forward to
start working on this thank you thank
you very much connectivity matters and
that was very clearly stated also in
this paper that is today in front of us
a connectivity is key for economic
development through trade and business
opportunity for social development and
of course for preserving our planet if
we do it right but above all it brings
people together and I think this is very
clear message from our communication
today the even Asia have an interest in
developing efficient economically viable
and environmentally sustainable trade
routes and corridors between the two
continents today 70% of all trade goes
by sea over 25% goes via air while rail
remains a very marginal and this story
the potential for growth is therefore
substantial that is why we want to
develop transport energy and digital
links between EU and Asia in the forum
of the three priorities of Frederica
already mentioned sustainable
connectivity comprehensive connectivity
international rule-based connectivity
and everything in the multilateral
spirit the EU has a rich experience with
building cross-border and multinational
networks for example the European
transport network also known as a 10 T
has a clear legal framework based on
corridors across the EU it is supported
by financial tools with a focus on
cross-border connectivity and very
clear standards for this purpose we are
ready to engage for with Asia with Asian
partners and share our successful
experiences towards an even closer
engagement we have extended the 10 T
Maps to Western Balkans two years ago
and now this is an incredible element of
our transport community treaty we agreed
the 10 t extension to Eastern
Partnership in our Eastern neighborhood
we are cooperating with Turkey really
well and I'm glad that we have a
high-level transport dialogue within
which we coordinate our joint
infrastructure plans we aim to develop
this multilateral engagement further
towards Asia in partnership with other
Asian countries for example with ASEAN
Japan and China as well as India we have
also established an EU China
connectivity platform and have been
engaging with them since 2016 we agreed
with China to make a study on the
railways corridors involving also the
transit countries and based on a level
playing field
well multilateral approach has been
honored furthermore in aviation and
maritime sectors we pursue agreements
with other countries to promote win-win
market access for example through the
negotiations of unprecedented
block-to-block agreement in aviation in
aviation we're also partnering with
other countries to negotiate
international agreements to decarbonize
the sector and I have to say we are
successful engaging with them through
the UN based international institutions
last but not least we are also committed
to provide financing to support
connectivity investments using our
successful tools such as connecting
Europe facility
better known as SEF and the investment
plan for Europe we are also successfully
deploying the externally
and plan to support investments in
partnership with international financial
institutions like World Bank EBRD and
EAB based on a guarantee and risk
sharing we have proposed to reinforce
these instruments in 2021 27 financial
period as well as you can see we have
been in gear engaging seriously with our
Asian partners for the last four years
and I'm really pleased that we now have
a very clear strategic framework within
we can continue our strategic
engagements thank you thank you very
much the floor is now yours please
introduce yourself in the media you're
working for before you ask your question
I seek your gear raising a hand Thank
You Maya your active vice president I
would like to know how much this is
going to be the highlight of the
upcoming summit and mr. response to the
Chinese rod and belt old Musial crowd
initiative and what's the difference you
mentioned international rule base does
it mean that you don't see rod and belt
enrolled as international based
thank you it will be a very edgy
oriented month because as you said we
will host here in Brussels the
asia-europe meeting summit on the 18th
and 19th of October and I believe that
before that the foreign ministers will
agree on this strategy at one of the
next four the first council and I can
tell you that already in my last
meetings with most of the Asian partners
during the last three four months over
the summer in particular I've started to
discuss the content of this strategy
with our partners in Asia starting with
China
but not only them Indian about ASEAN
countries many that are interested in
looking at the european way to improve
connectivity and increase connectivity
between Asia and Europe coming to the
second part of your question I think I
partially responded when I mentioned
China in among the interlocutors with
whom we have started to discuss the
strategy even before presenting it
our approach is confident enough I would
say not to measure our proposals as
reactions to others there might be
differences there might be points in
common for sure we share the same the
same approach in the identification of
the need and the priority we both share
with China the strategic relevance and
the will to increase connectivity
between Europe and Asia there might be
also differences indeed we believe that
any investment in increase in
connectivity has to be based on
international rules and regulations that
are for us a guarantee that things are
done properly that players have the same
opportunities that communities benefit
from the projects this is another aspect
that characterizes the European approach
to connectivity and that I've discussed
a lot in particular with Central Asian
partners but also with others our
projects will aim at creating also jobs
and economic growth and benefits for the
local communities our approach is this
and we believe that this is sustainable
and good for us and also for the
societies and the economies of the
countries where our companies operate I
would not say myself if this is
different from others proposal but this
is our proposal and again it's not a
response but for sure it's it's a common
need we see it's a common priority we
identify and there are I believe points
of contact on which we can work very
well and there are as usual also
differences in the approach but this is
natural
thanks Maya hi reppin the Belton Road
initiative was put forward in 2013 so
why are you coming forward with this
proposal now towards the end of the
commission and almost six years after
China is not determined elsewhere we
come with a proposal when we see the
proposal is ready when we have good
ideas and we have resources to put on it
when we see things as a priority for us
and I think you're later explained
perfectly well why this is interesting
for Europe today and again as it is not
a reaction in negative terms to another
initiative it is not a reaction in
positive terms to another initiative I
will never I will never be tired of
saying and explaining the calendar of
our decisions the statements we do the
strategies we put forward the consensus
we create inside the European Union is
not based on calendars determined
elsewhere being it in Beijing make it in
Washington baguette in Moscow baguette
in Timbuktu you name it we define
European policies on the basis of what
is in the best interests of Europeans
most of the times this coincides also
with the interests of the rest of the
world especially today so there's no
link with with a calendar with a
timeline of others there is an interest
we identify as Europeans to work
together as Europeans now on this and
putting at the disposal also of our
private sector the financial resources
to support their work in this field also
because we have been fostering in this
last couple of years as you might have
noticed an external not only the
external investment plan but what we
would call the economic diplomacy in an
incredible manner that was not there
before so I would say that this is also
part of our increased work to support
European investments and the economic
presence of the European
of the European players in other parts
of the world also because we see there
is a demand for that again let me
mention sorry I'm long but I'll close
here let me mention the fact that in
some of my talks again in particular in
Central Asia I clearly saw for the first
time probably the need and the demand
for not only economic investments but
for quality standards in the investments
projects that can create infrastructures
that are not just cheap and affordable
but also that can resist the test of
time that connect with the European
standards of quality and it is something
that probably the demand for that was
not there before or the interest for
that was not there before so much on the
European side and this is the result I
believe of a good work that has been
done including by commercial rules on
developing the European stand and and
presence in the global transport
environment in in the world globally I
see two more questions I'll ask you to
be really short and I'll take both and
then we conclude I'll start with you and
then I move to please go ahead
good morning I represented a Malibu Nene
initiative we have a question on
migration for me because African Union
officially asked mr. salvini to
apologize for his a statement on African
migrants and slavery so since you have
been work
Union to find to find a good cooperation
mood for this migration phenomenon
vehicles are you concerned about the
possibilities of sort of diplomatic
crisis since the Italy is one of the new
member states thank you I would say that
here today we discuss about connectivity
between Europe and Asia I'll fly to
Salzburg tonight and there they will
discuss about other things related to
migration one more question over there
Venables in Dodge efficacy Tom I
understand that you will take this
connectivity model to Asia this provokes
the question what happens if Asia
doesn't have any interest in the
European way to see things thank you for
what I see up to now there's a lot of
interest in the last couple of months
I've been traveling to Asia I've been
having I guess some twenty bilateral
meetings I check with my Asian
counterparts different countries
including regional organizations I think
about them and there is a lot of demand
and interest in having the European way
to connectivity in the continent not
only in the continent but also with the
continent and with what is in between
Europe and Asia
so the demand is there the interest is
there obviously we will need to discuss
the details and once this proposal is
now on the table this will be obviously
done and again on the on the transport
aspects this is not a job for me but
more for you later as well as there are
other aspects of the proposal I
mentioned digital I mentioned energy
that are of the components of other
commissioners we will do this
comprehensive approach now in practical
terms and as I said October will be a
month where we start few weeks from now
a month exactly from now with the Azzam
summit I'm sure that connectivity will
feature as the top priority for our
common agenda so this is also in
preparation for the Assam summit and I
can tell you for the time being the
interest we're seeing from all our Asian
partners and I stress all our Asian
partners it's very high maybe I can just
add one additional argument I mean
global trade is growing more and more
every country is realizing that in order
to really engage either for trade other
economical reasons or even on a social
engagement you need connectivity in a
sense of transport and I can see a
really growing interest from Asia to
connect better with EU explained before
we've been connected only
I sea and by air so far and some very
limited capacity in railways however if
the industry tried to cooperate if we
want to really get export and import
going we really need to get common
standards we need to have common
alignments of regulatory rules and we
started at the beginning of the mandate
discussions with our Asian partners and
now things are evolving accumulating and
it was a really perfect dynamic now to
come up with the overall support
communication from the Commission as
well that doesn't mean that we are
conflicting or competing like Frederica
said with anybody but you need a its own
story with which we can engage now in
you even more coordinated and strategic
matter I'll take one final question for
field
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's undercoat a liquid to feed upon
say a lamp act knows economy not
commerce this dismal been done sector
the connectivity honest II say no don't
refer medio de l'épée on public help ntp
that expose assertive data school may
tolerate a la connectivity episode no
economy
you see des otra parte del economy come
lo tourism key benefits if Abu Lahab
Unterman the connectivity a classy
nobody on popular la Sierra Akshay
Annamma on development
Donaire the fake Center continued addict
la francaise la protección la provision
the croissants economical applaud Duke
Lynette don't get young connected a
closet an anti-economic problem a PB&J
could derail so shall the p12 Co not
even definitive is 12
Logopolis Gionta t-connector it's a a to
droop I mean you're not gonna go to be
not 20 baddha konasana cultural men not
whenever the spirituality super to
she'll see the suspect in Norman's not
rapid ancestor the press Sarah an le
monde de our she's English she small a
man in a perpetual system is responsible
for say this conclude this presentation
please hand over the floor now to
Alexander and immediately after we
proceed with the technical briefing on
the same connectivity strategy thank you
very much